one in ten children will experience
sexual abuse before their 18th birthday
[Music]
that's that doesn't surprise me but it's
very scary I mean if you think of your
kids class that's like two or three kids
in the class or being abused I have one
son who's 10 years old he is starting to
reach the age where he will be alone
with adults that he is essentially being
told to trust today we'll be taking the
darkness to light training to prevent an
end to child sexual abuse I want to take
this training because it feels like a
responsibility of society to take care
of our children and I have nieces and
nephews we should be making sure as a
society that our children feel safe and
are safe my son is not a huge talker
biggest thing I would want to learn is
what our behavioral changes in him that
I would notice that are just normal for
his age or actually something's wrong
and then what are the tools I can give
him in a situation that he needs to
protect themselves the format of the
training it's two hours long what we're
going to be learning is five steps of
how to protect kids you can only protect
your child so much when you run around
with them so how do you teach them this
balance of protecting themselves but
also not being afraid that was very
insightful made me think about a lot of
things that I had not necessarily
considered like reducing risk through
just how many doors are open or how many
adults are in a room with a bunch of
kids at once in schools the main thing
to remember is observable and interrupts
ibill if you're talking to a teacher
camp counselor just making sure that are
their windows you can actually see in
can the door be left open it's very
uncomfortable we talked about this stuff
you never want to seem like you're mean
or crazy but it is important to just be
uncomfortable and say you know I want to
actually know about this because I'm
entrusting my children to you as someone
who doesn't have children it was really
interesting to learn what to be aware of
and to feel more confident about
actually using body heart names a big
part of our job is to teach kids that
their bodies are their own and they have
choice and how they use their bodies and
how it's touched or not touched always
talking with your kids you know keeping
the conversation open so that they can
feel comfortable telling you and another
big part is using anatomically correct
terms or their body part a lot of time
when you grow up especially as a young
girl you don't refer to your vagina as a
vagina you use like other names for it I
think it's really important for a kid to
know the correct name for something so
that they can talk about it correctly
just like they know what
IRA's what an elbow is they should know
like what their vagina is one thing that
surprised me even though I expected a
little bit was just how close to the to
the family and the survivors the people
who usually did abuse were this
stranger-danger thing is just not
anything that is in our hands and is so
little compared to fact that over 90
percent of kids who are abused or abused
by people they know that the parents
often know you know these people are
arrested by the family they're really
clicked when they brought up the concept
of reducing possibility for incidents
and exposure so that made me really
think like oh like if I come home early
and the babysitter's not expecting me if
I pick him up early from the Walker room
for football whoever would possibly
think about crossing the boundary with
my child or another child may think
twice if they're surprised and it makes
it more difficult I never thought like
oh there are things that I can do to
protect him I always thought there was
just you have conversations and you make
sure you know who they're with but I
think there's a lot more systemic things
we can do and making that a practice I
think is something I will definitely do
and the other really great thing I
learned for cybersecurity is turning off
Wi-Fi at night I've always thought
turning Wi-Fi off was a punishment now I
actually see it as a protection for him
we really did have a Hannibal affect my
ability to prevent or spot something
like this from happening I mean if
there's a 1% chance that they'll help me
stop a case of child abuse from
happening then it's absolutely worth a
couple hours of my time there is
prevalence to this problem and it just
looks like so many different things
later in life and then people have too
much shame and stigma to talk about it
there is a line you know with PTSD
substance abuse depression so many
health problems the other day my kids
had a play day the mom texted me and
said sorry to ask this but I always ask
this do you have guns and if you do are
they locked up I feel as passionately
and strongly and hopefully we will get
to a point where child sex abuse will be
talked about that openly we talk about
how we don't want our kids to be in
those situations but there really isn't
a lot of talk that we have about
actionable things we can do to save our
kids or to keep them safe from these
kind of situations that's why was great
but the training is that it was giving
us a lot of actionable things we could
do to help safeguard our kids it's a
one-time to our thing
and you could save someone or more than
one person a lifetime of pain so why not
go
[Music]